I can't ask how you are cuz I feel like
you've been all over the place man and
you're performing tonight how you holdin
up right now it's been a busy few weeks
we got back from vacation a few weeks
ago and just been non-stop ever since
and got a lot goin on a lot of great
things product launches you got all
kinds of crazy things happening to kids
boys I mean here's the thing John you're
like the nicest guy ever and that shows
a little competitive who are you gonna
come for who's your biggest competition
out there we don't realize how
competitive I am I'm ready to win
but I believe my theory with winning is
just focus on yourself and don't worry
about everybody else and as long as you
do the best you can yeah it'll work out
who do you I mean Blake's got a lot of
wins under his belt but do you know any
of them a little bit from beforehand
like who are you really gonna I'm pretty
close with Adam we've known each other
for a long time and I work together with
Kelly and I'm very very close with her -
we did a show together called duets it
didn't last long but we had a great time
working together and I just love her as
a vocalist and personality and
everything so we're gonna have fun
together
I don't know Blake as well but uh well
we'll get to know everybody on the show
what made you want to do it cuz we heard
that you were really like I want to go
do the show well I think it's first of
all just a fun show to do it's fun to
just be in America's living rooms and
and have the banter with the other
coaches and then also discover new
talent it's just a fun thing to do are
we gonna get Christine miles on set
because I know that they go to lip sync
battle set I go to lip sync battle set
the babies go I think Chrissy do the
same with us cheering for you and the
whole thing and how proud are you of her
right now the whole line at Target it's
amazing I'm so excited her book just
came out this week I know it's gonna be
right up there on the bestseller list
and we're excited all that all the good
things are happening right now I'm just
proud of her and and excited for us
together even though she called you the
pushover parents she said that is that
true I am easier to convince in it
the mom is you know I'm so laid back
it's just hard for me to like say no
last question for you I know that you
guys been hanging out the queer eye guys
lately saw them at the Emmys if you had
to pick like do you need any one of
those guys do you need a little help
from any of them I think I got my life
together pretty well I mean I know how
to dress another cook I know that how I
want my house decorate I mean I don't
know I don't think I need the queer eyes
I'm gonna do my own show and you know
make people over you got your beautiful
lady by your side I love that Instagram
post your posts about it you guys are so
happy right now right all as well
[Music]